did you hear donald trump was nominated
for a nobel peace prize
we went to cnn for comment
[Music]
good year oh man we went to rachel
maddow for comment
we went to the washington post for
comment
true in a decision sure to entice smirks
from the media and political class
trump's been nominated for brokering a
landmark peace deal between israel and
the united arab emirates
this after bringing serbia and kosovo to
the table as well
it's this thaw between arab and jew the
dems could never do
because dissent keeps the left relevant
but for the non-ideologue with no
sunk cost in the past trump's the right
man to unmuddle the middle east
imagine the poor cnn viewer always told
how trump hates jews and muslims
and yet it's trump and his jewish
son-in-law bringing muslims and jews
together
how can this be well cnn viewers it's
their business model without division
cnn's got nothing
but let's not forget north korea the
media wants you to
but remember before trump that nation
was on the verge of nuking us
then trump upended that psychology now
north and south korea are kind of
talking
and no one in hawaii thinks they're
going to die of course trump won't win
the prize he's despised
by the cool kids at the cafeteria table
which is why they're more obsessed with
hearsay and private conversations
than his deeds deeds that brought us
less war
and more peace so now the whiners
falsely blame trump's rhetoric
for the pandemic as well as the violence
in democrat-led
cities it's all the left has left
distorting trump's words because his
deeds speak for themselves
kennedy i've been saying this all along
i'll take the most obnoxious person in
the world
if they bring peace to the world isn't
that what trump's doing
i think actually he does best on foreign
policy
and i agree there's a lot about
the way he comports himself personally
and digitally
that is not that rad and he he leaves
a lot to be desired with his personality
about 15 people said that during the
republican national convention
but you do have to look at the proof
in his foreign policy and give him
credit where credit is due
and please don't try and diminish uh
that deal between uae
and israel that's that's a very big deal
because uae is looking
at a future beyond fossil fuels
and you know if that's what it takes to
normalize relations with israel
is economic prosperity in the future i
will take that brand of peace
any day and you know you if if you take
him
out of it and look at the
accomplishments i have to say he
deserves the price
dana from a scale of one being banana
to 1343 which means
awesome banana where would you put this
piece of cord
well i think that one he certainly is
more deserving of it than the
aspirational geopolitical participation
trophy that was given to
president obama uh even before he was in
office
um so there's that but i also think that
this uae is real deal
while some people might say well they
weren't in conflict directly et cetera
i actually think that this deal is
important but i think that what it
portends for the future
is even more important because you're
going to have other countries within the
middle east follow
hopefully follow the uae's lead juan
it's uh 39 years i believe uh since uh
we've initiated that's been the longest
the only president in 39 years not to
initiate a military conflict
you kind of like that right
uh you know i think this deal you know
potentially could be good news although
i noticed that the
other arab countries the palestinians
have not embraced it but look not a
country hundreds of people
get nominated a lot hundreds of people
get nominated for a nobel prize
every year in fact the same right-wing
politician who nominated
trump for this one also nominated him
for 2018 for
working with north korea and kim jong-un
is still still firing missiles off
and still trying to create trouble so i
i don't get it
in the woodward book in fact uh he's
still doing it and in fact in the
woodward book
they have it they have a scene in which
you said uh you get the president saying
when he met kim jong-un he knew it was
gonna work it's like you meet a special
woman
in a second you know if it's going to
happen oh my god this is too much
yeah it's called words but we're trying
to focus on the deeds jessie
what do you make of this i reviewed all
of the winners since 1904 and here's my
summary greg
okay there are some obvious choices you
have fdr
you have george marshall mandela mlk and
then you have some major snubs denatus
and bretton woods i'd even have given it
to 41 for the cold war or even reagan
and then you have people that you
scratch your head like barack obama
and then there's people you've just
never heard they push papers at the u.n
who knows what they did they wrote a
book or something
but if you look at the presidency so far
just objectively if you lower the
temperature
on the korean peninsula if you remove
troops from germany
from syria from afghanistan and iraq you
decimate isis you do a peace deal with
arabs
and you do a peace deal with kosovo
objectively speaking
that is enough to qualify you for this
because the criteria
done the best work for the fraternity of
nations the abolition or reduction of
standing armies
and for holding the promotion of peace
congresses i agree with kennedy
i'd send his mouth to the hague but
i would give the results the peace prize
[Laughter]
somebody got to bed early because you
did quite a lot of research there jessie
johnny did it
johnny he deserves a nobel prize for
being your assistant